We've been fixed for now.
Uh, several months.
We wondered what Emmanuel Macron,
his majority,
uh parliamentarian and his government were simmering
on immigration.
Now we know,
associated with the nupc.
And yes,
you heard that right,
to this extreme left that has become neutral.
Well,
some government MPs
propose 1 law to
regularize undocumented migrants.
You heard me right.
At a time when France undergoes every year
the arrival of half a 1,000,000 legal migrants,
not to mention
isolated minors and illegal migrants,
and the government and its majority do not find
nothing better
than to tell us,
all these migrants,
uh illegals who work
will have to be regularized tomorrow.
Do they have 1 second
think of those 5,000,000 French people who are unemployed?
Did they think
1 second to these crates
who are in deficit because of immigration?
Did they think for a second about all those rape victims,
of attacks that are very often
to legal or illegal migrants?
No,
not 1 second,
not 1 second.
They
had the idea to take common sense solutions
that we offer
with Marine Le Pen and Jordan Bardella,
the end of family,
border control,
the systematic expulsion of illegal migrants
or foreigners who have committed crimes and misdemeanors,
the end of certain social benefits
for those who have just arrived in our country.
The end of course also free care
for all these illegal immigrants
illegal immigrants who come for treatment in France
while 2 out of 5 French people have already given up on Care,
no,
this government
leads the foreign preference strategy
where the Rassemblement National alone wants to establish
the national priority.
Rather than creating low cost jobs
by regularizing illegal migrants,
let's raise wages to allow the French to
work tomorrow
and be rewarded
precisely from this work.
1 measure of the credibility of Marine Le Pen
said that if 1 employer increases wages by 10%,
these 10% will be exempt from the employer's charge.
This is 1 good measure
which allows the French to work
and protects us from uncontrolled immigration.
So quickly,
as Jordan Dardella requests,
let's do 1 real gesture on immigration at the same time
time that the European elections
on the next nine/06.
The National Rally
is the only party
to protect yourself from this uncontrolled immigration
and have concrete solutions.
Never
to trust Emmanuel Macron and his majority.
Now I think it's clear.